[Music]
wonder woman
[Music]
i'm this is my line oh not yet let me do
the thing
ready one two three do it don't go
so it doesn't go all the way
swear to god this is like
[Music]
what is it
oh out of it okay do you want to try one
more let me
just go back to the top right
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
diane i've got some bad news treat me
like
[Music]
be giovanni
[Music]
you truly delight me who are you
laughing
[Laughter]
[Music]
of course the hugh vernon washington
series aren't going to win
any prizes for you
you can't possibly understand or him oh
i can't possibly understand
oh my god are you okay
[Music]
style smile what we got forgotten
who would wear it let's try something
else i'm not even wearing underwear
that's how comfortable these pants are
really yeah
i think it's going to drop too much
[Music]
[Applause]
attention
[Music]
intently i'm listening intently
i am so invested in this
okay i'll pretend you guys
as the world turns okay gal will giggle
at the air
i'm ready
[Music]
you're wrong time to be sexy
[Music]
he doesn't see what he's doing to me i'm
not doing it
[Music]
ready
okay wait a second
just a second
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
good
ready um
so cool oh my god these plants are so
big
what far all the place hey steve this
way
oh man i love flounder
[Music]
just farted i heard that
[Music]
cut
[Music]